it's BIOS leave house lifespan extending
Villa
we want to reverse the downhill course
of human life and architecture is the
perfect means for doing it if we change
what surrounds you we can change you I
actually slept in here last night you
know you kind of open you come out and
you open up onto this space anything
this wonderful big space I'll go down to
the kitchen and you know mixing it some
coffee
so in fact in some ways it's it's it's
absolutely familiar in that you can do
everything you would do anywhere else
here and the only difference is that you
just have to think about how you do
everything
yeah it means to strengthen the immune
system it has to do with not being so
damned sure of yourself by oh sweet
house has built into it the means to
return you to that but has this uneven
terrain and you you're obliged to watch
your balance carefully you get at least
the moment of flatness in the floor and
you come to the threshold and you know
you're at there you're at the mountain
edge there so you know you're gonna have
to be a billy goat to get to the to the
coffee so the difference between going
rock climbing in the great outdoors and
being in a house and heading for the
kitchen or heading for the bathroom is
that you have to negotiate it even as
you head toward recognizable
destinations that are part of your
everyday action within your home so
you're you're caught between in a way so
all of that is this tentativeness that
we think is very desirable to get to
everything is is oddly scaled here that
the dimensions of the walls the size of
the pools all the outlets and things are
tilted and again if you're trying to
find
you know this isn't gonna help you
alright so where are you gonna find the
level in the house
what is the front cut through the back
other double-barrel or that's tens if it
was a second so constantly you're
getting this sort of contrasting
information and it's not like oh that's
world shattering information it's just
subtle sort of jars to what you expect
and if you if you're constantly getting
information that's against what you
expect you either collapse or you have
to open open to how well I have to
figure it out a different way if you
have to figure it out a different way
you're using different sorts of
capacities so that's that's the basis of
the body as technology then needs that
thing from the outside to come back in
to help it to actually give it the
context in which it can change
immunologist of studying our work and
they're they're kind of finding it to be
true yeah so do you feel younger yeah
yeah I mean you know that's a that's a
joke because they're reversible this
Andy Hotel you know you come and stay
for a week and you you leave what ten
minutes younger or something like that
if the question is how to vitalize your
life how to become more viable how to
you decide how to live your life I
definitely feel those things but in
terms of you know like do you have an
instant effect of this no no definitely
not but I don't I don't really think
that that's just a promotional tool the
the real longevity factor will be in the
way that it sustains you throughout life
rather than I think the instinct pill
that you can take
you